something I've learned since Miyamura started coming to my house.
Sometimes I opened it with a safety pin
And then
[music]
2 It's a little strange, but I'm
not very
good at studying.  I
once again realize that my impression was completely different
What was the supermarket leaflet?
Unless it's an urgent committee meeting, I'll pick up the eggs and
come back.
Homeroom is over.
Applause]
Even if it's just up -
20 minutes left
Shortcut ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
Air battle
That overwintering
What happened to the person you call snow
?  I don't
want you to see me
dressed like that, it's not rice or
anything, forget about it.
You know, I
wake up with a pretty loud voice, and
actually, at home, there are people who have nice hair every once in a while, and the way
their muscles are attached is
pretty good.
I don't like it, I
think this time is only for me